I got to meet a bunch of people from uh
from your team it's just an incredible
human being so let me just ask on that
topic how do you hire a great team like
what have you learned about hiring for
um everything for it for the main
channel that you do uh for the the react
again uh the the gaming channel to uh Mr
Beast Burger to uh feastables all that
the big thing is especially in this
content creation because it's not like
anything that's done on Netflix or or
different uh content mediums I I really
need people who are coachable and like
really see the value in what I care
about because it's a very specific way
of going about things and it's a like a
thing there's no one like Plug and Play
like if Netflix wanted to hire someone
to do a documentary there's probably
tens of thousands of people you could
hire that have worked on documentaries
before but if you want to hire someone
to make super viral YouTube videos you
know like we do there's just no one you
you can really pull from like sometimes
I'll hire people from uh game shows
right they have all these preconceived
notions about pacing and how video
should be and you have to spend like the
first year like breaking all these
habits and you know and they think
they're better than you like a lot of
people in traditional think they're
better and they think their way is
better than what we do and so for me
it's almost easier to hire people that
are just hard workers that are obsessed
and really coachable and just train them
how to like be good at content creation
production than to hire someone from
like traditional which is the only way
to really do it because there's not that
many YouTube channels that have scaled
up so it's not like there's a huge
talent pool of people who've worked on
YouTube channels
um so it's easier just to train someone
than just pull them from traditional
because traditional people just I don't
know they have all these opinions and
things and they just think our way of
going about things is dumb yeah so you
want people who have the humility to
have a beginner's mind even if they have
experience and see the value like
actually you'll still get it it's so
crazy like especially some of my other
friends that are Skilling up their
YouTube channels there's people that
will come on and you'll ask them like
what do you want to be doing in five
years and instead of saying oh I want to
be working on this channel they'll be
like oh I hope to be workout movies or
this and they see like working on a
YouTube channels the launch pad to go
into traditional and it's like no like
you just don't get it this is the future
is the end goal this is your career
um and so I'm just so tired of having
those kinds of conversations like I feel
like people really should be coming
around are there like recurring
interview questions that you ask is
there is there ways to get yeah the
biggest thing is like what do you want
to be doing in 10 years and their answer
isn't you know making content on YouTube
or you know if their answer is anything
like movies or traditional stuff like
that it's like just a hell no like it
just won't even remotely work oh so you
really want people to believe in the
vision of YouTube yeah I mean ideally
it's like oh working here you know what
I mean so it's less about the medium and
more about just being on a great team
that's doing epic stuff yeah well and
yeah the media as well because those
it's just it's hard to
put into words but there's it's just two
completely different ways of going about
things you know like our videos aren't
scripted and you know it's a lot more
Run and Gun and when we if we
hypothetically blow up a giant car or
whatever like you only have one take you
know I mean so
um and it's not scripted and so you have
to over film overshoot things over
compensate for like the dumb way of
going about it and a lot of traditional
people would be like well just plan what
you're gonna say and just playing the
angles you can cut the cameras in half
you can save 50 Grand here you can save
a you know 75 000 editing this and that
and it's like yeah but that's not
authentic like that's you know but you
you get it it's it's almost so obvious
that it hurts to have to like constantly
have these conversations but so what we
live in but there's also detail like
there's a taste like I've watched a
bunch of videos with you and it's clear
to you that you've gotten really good
I don't know what the right word is
style or taste to be able to know what's
good and not in terms of retention in
terms of yeah just stylistically
visually I don't have to think I can
just watch a video and it just it just
screams in my head like this is what
this is what should change based on the
you know million videos I've watched and
all these viral videos are consumed like
this is blah blah what's optimal and
things like that it's almost like your
brain's like a you know like a neural
net and like if you consume enough viral
videos and enough good content that you
just kind of start to like train your
brain to like see it and see these
patterns that happen in all these viral
videos and so that anytime I watch a
video or a movie or anything I just
can't stop thinking about what is
optimal and so it's like it gives me a
headache sometimes when I watch
something too slow or I don't think it's
optimal obviously my taste isn't the
end-all feel
um but that's something that kind of
torments me if that makes any sense
oh you can't enjoy a slow moving no
movie and that's not to say there's
attention on The Godfather is horrible
yeah no exactly I've tried to watch that
movie like three times but and that's
not to say slow movies are bad like
there's an audience for it it's just
obviously not what I've trained my brain
to like and and social media and YouTube
right now like that's just not the meta
and in general like you said in neural
network you're training your brain
in part on actual data
right so you're actually it's data
driven so you're looking at like in
terms of thumbnails and titles and
different aspects of the first five ten
seconds and then throw out the video the
retention all that you're looking at all
that
uh for your own videos to understand how
to do it better so that's where the
neural network is training yeah
basically there are ways you can kind of
see like the most view videos on YouTube
every day and stuff like that and I just
kind of consume those every single day
and I've been doing that for way too
many years and then you just start to
notice patterns like the thumbnails on
the most view videos or videos that go
super viral tend to be clear tend to not
have much clutter tend to be pretty
simple titles tend to be less than 50
characters intros tend to be this
stories tend to be this and you just
kind of like after you see those
thousands and then tens of thousands of
time it just starts to click in your
head like this is what it looks like you
know so how are you able to transfer
that taste that you've developed to the
team so for like because you said like
broad things but I'm sure there's a
million detailed things like what Zoom
to use on the face to use in the
thumbnail right like the answer is
whatever makes the best video because
the problem is the more
which I have so many friends who are
like this they'll make like checklists
for their editor or something like you
know uh this be in this beat and you
need to have like a three part Arc and
then this but the the problem is that's
how you the the more constraints you put
on the team the more repetitive and less
Innovation you get and the more like you
know after 10 videos people are gonna be
like all right I've already seen this so
to me and I'm 24 and you know I'm
probably my mindset will change over the
next 10 years I just haven't been in
this industry too long but the only way
to like really make Innovative content
and keep things fresh is to not put
constraints on or put as little as
possible and so that's why I'm very
hesitant on all that stuff because the
more I say the more they're gonna be
like oh then that's what we do and then
you know I'll say one time like oh you
know ideally there's a cut every three
seconds and then next thing you know
every video there's like cut every three
seconds or whatever so it's it's hard
because I try to give uh as little
train not training but as little uh
facts or as possible and more just make
suggestions if that makes any you mean
publicly or to your team to my team yeah
what was so you talked about sort of uh
teaching your voice or your style
whatever we want to call it to other
people on the team so they can be kind
of a Mr B's replacement
so what's the process of teaching that
so you don't wanna no you're more
talking about like uh what I would call
almost like cloning right like like
Tyler and other things like that yeah so
when we were hanging out today I was
showing him how we have multiple people
and they come it's it's almost like
talking to the cameras yeah it turns
slowly to the camera I was like anyways
have it is it weird to you to not be
looking at the camera this whole
interview I constantly have been turning
towards the camera like yeah I'm talking
to him yes it's a habit uh because my
whole life I've just been talking to a
camera who are you thinking about when
you're looking at the camera do you like
imagine somebody I'm fully thinking
about the person just sitting watching
it and I almost it's weird but I'm
looking at the camera I don't see a
camera I'm like in a haze picturing what
the viewer is seeing when they watch it
yeah that makes sense and that's where
I'll be saying things and or doing
something and then like when I'm
watching I'm like that's not what I want
and then I'll freeze up it's very weird
when I'm filming and then for people who
haven't worked with me too much they'll
think like I don't know it's very weird
like the how I go about it because I'll
just be doing whatever like lighting a
firework all right this is a thousand
dollar firework I'll go to light of it
and I'll like freeze because in my head
I'm like this I don't know I don't like
how that float or how that shot looked
because I it's weird I can perfectly
picture what I'm filming by just looking
at the camera and then putting myself
through the lens of the camera while
making content I can do it at the same
time so you're like real time editing in
my video yeah that's something that
didn't at the start come natural to me
but in the last probably like five years
it's happened and so I would say it's
one of my greatest strengths but I don't
know how I developed it but anytime I'm
filming anything like it's almost like
the like right side of my brain I just
can just look at it I see exactly what
I'm filming and I can just picture it
well there's probably do recording the
video being the talent for the video and
then watching the editing and like
analyzing you carefully and do that over
and over again ten thousand times yeah
you do the editing more than the being
in front of the camera so like you
you start to see yourself from that
third person perspective exactly then
maybe that actually helps with the
nerves of it too like you see it as
creating a video versus performing uh
right yeah yeah I think so you know I
it's weird I've never
been nervous talking to a camera it's
it's harder for me to talk to a person
that doesn't talk to a camera which I
feel like a lot of people say that
though that are whatever make content
right interesting I've heard that so
many times
or maybe not maybe I'm just awkward
enough maybe they're practiced I to me
it's I mean both are terrifying but
being in front of the camera about
yourself is so much easier really yeah
so much easier I preferred a million
times over
[Applause]
but that's my whole life you know so
it's just that's why it's interesting
like you've spent more of your time
talking to people yeah it comes natural
and I talk to
a piece of plastic oh yeah I guess
you're talking to a person too they're
just then on the other side of the
camera yeah there's just a pixel on the
screen so so cloning how do you how do
you achieve this oh yeah that's right
that's all around show so I was showing
him that I have a lot of people in the
company who are able to think like me
and uh basically make decisions like I
would make if I was like if you were
asked hey in this video should we climb
a mountain or should we dig a hole right
and like you know they would pick the
same answer I'd pick 90 plus percent of
the times and so one example is Tyler
who I was showing you and he was
pitching some content and you could see
it like this he was on point and uh
basically for just four or five years we
just spent an absurd amount of time
together and worked on every single
video together and we worked uh side by
side and same thing with uh my CEO James
he literally lived with me for a couple
years I'm a big fan of just like finding
people who are super obsessed and all in
and a players that you know they really
just want to be great and then just
dumping everything
and like you were saying because I'd
love to find that uh and develop that
you're saying you're basically for a
long time just said everything you were
thinking to them exactly like uh James
the the guy who's basically my right
handman right now
um for two years he lived with me and we
probably talked on average of those two
years seven hours a day I mean anytime I
had a phone call I'd throw it on speaker
and I'd let him listen anything I was
reading any content I was consuming like
really just training his brain to think
like me so that way
um he could just do things without my
input without me having to constantly
watch over him or give him advice and
and that's where we've gotten like so
for the first six months he didn't do
anything he just studied me and studied
everything I cared about and how I spoke
and blah blah and then the next six
months he started taking on some
responsibilities and now he can just run
the company and you know I don't ever
really have to check in on him like I
most the decisions he makes are exactly
what I would do
um and so I I call that cloning I don't
know what other people would but it's
just like finding people that are really
obsessed and they just kind of really
want it and just being like giving them
an Avenue to like get it if that makes
any sense another way to see it is
you're converging towards a common
vision and that makes like brainstorming
much more productive yeah it just makes
it where I don't have to be so involved
in everything because I just have these
people I know will think like I will uh
at least relatively close to it so I can
kind of almost be in multiple places at
once per se and so these things that you
know I still approve every idea we film
and you know everything before we film
it all the creative I prove it but I
don't have to like be in the weeds and
nuances and do all this minor stuff I
can just let them handle it I can just
do the more macro things